this is uh this is huge news there's a
letter released by Jim Jordan showing
that uh what's his name Michael Morell
is that his name former CIA director
outright said that he he told people the
hunter Biden laptop was this information
because he wanted to help Joe Biden win
right right at the direction of Tony
blinken who's now the Secretary of State
and I think he talked to Biden too
didn't he yeah I I think you know Biden
was involved but it was through the
intermediary who who only of course you
know talked about people like mayor Pete
getting promoted Tony blanket of course
now in a very Prime position there as
Secretary of State and this story does
not get covered very very much in the in
the corporate media these days I mean
this this came out in a house Judiciary
panel Mike Morrell not a partisan guy at
all but just is asked to tell what
happened here well no he is I mean he
said he wanted Biden to win Mike well
yes but but not you know he he was doing
the bidding of of Tony blinken a a
trustworthy person let's just say that I
mean this is not someone who's like you
know try trying to to right I mean to
your point a guy from the left is
essentially admitting to what he was
doing uh yeah the that story I mean
again a companion to the hunter Biden
lack of coverage Hunter by laptop lack
of coverage was that story which would
you know the way that yes cnns of the
world and I've I've talked to a lot of
people at CNN about this okay you didn't
say it was Russian disinformation but
you put that letter out there with
people said it was 50 all the former
agents of Russian right and those people
who you pay in many instances people
like Clapper and Brennan are getting
paychecks from MSNBC and CNN they're the
ones who are telling you look looks like
Russian disinformation to us you know
we're the experts you know experts again
take a look at this we got to start from
the examiner it says Morel who testified
to Congress earlier this month about the
laptop letter said he thought now
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
wanted the baseless claims of Russian
involvement in the Saigon made public
the former Obama acting CIA director
told house investigators that before was
October 17th call with blinken he had no
intention to like the October 19th
Hunter Biden laptop letter and testified
yes and absolutely when asked if the
call with blinken who was the top
advisor for Biden's 2020 campaign was uh
what was what triggered that intent in
you
Morel also said in a recent transcribed
interview with Congressional
investigators that it was his guest that
Lincoln called him to talk about the
hunter Biden laptop because the future
Secretary of State wanted it out in the
public that the Russians Were Somehow
involved in the Saga he also testified
that one of the two reasons he helped
put the letter together was to help now
President Joe Biden quote because I
wanted him to win the election
hey how about that what a what a what a
what a time to be alive huh insane and
no punishment for blatant election
interference but you know a question
that I have is these guys weaponize this
entire process to win the 2020 election
right you got a bunch of former Intel
guys partnered with social media
engaging in this in this clear
manipulation of multiple systems just to
get their guy in they were able to even
if you don't want to discuss the the
issue of election fraud they were able
to weaponize this system enough to be
able to prevent Trump from getting
reelected when he wielded the full power
of the executive branch of the United
States government what is what has
changed and let me add one other uh
point in here too we have numerous
States like Pennsylvania that change
election laws in the run-up to the
election to give Democrats an advantage
and prevent Trump from getting in none
of this Republicans were involved in
that right so what has changed since
2020 that they would this deep State
apparatus would allow him back in now
when they've already weaponized the
system preventing to prevent him from
getting into
I don't know if I don't know if I would
phrase it as prevent him I think what
they're trying to do is slant things as
heavily as possible in their favor and
that I think is the game and I think
Republicans need to pay attention to
that they spent too long coming out
screaming fraud fraud fraud instead of
screaming how are they getting these
ballots how are they doing it and then
just doing the same thing ballot chasing
harvesting now Trump is coming out and
being like we're going to do the same
thing now you're hearing Republicans
come out say okay we figured it out
we're going to play the game they're
playing now I think these advantages may
be lost because if Republicans actually
start playing the same game it's going
to slowly bounce out though Universal
mail-in voting greatly advantages
Democrats in dense populated areas and
it's very hard for people in rural areas
to get the word out and things like that
but I think I think Republicans can now
understanding what happened in the past
two elections start utilizing that
properly so we'll see I'm I'm not I
don't want to be black filled on this
one well I I think you're right I mean
the last two elections because that
clearly was a factor in 2022 also in the
midterm absolutely that the fact that
they hadn't made those adjustments at
that point was it was a clear thing but
I honestly think you know going back to
something you said earlier about the
social media incentives uh what what was
the the real story about this I mean why
did so many in the media not cover this
when I went back and started looking for
the book about why was the Press covered
that you know why do they cover it this
way they there were people like Maggie
Haberman at the New York Times who
linked to the New York Post just said oh
I questioned the sourcing of it I don't
know this seems a little shady and she
got trending on Twitter as Maga Haberman
because she linked to the New York Post
even because she was she was and so Jake
Sherman who's now at punch bowl he was
at Politico at the time
yeah he tweets it also I wonder if the
Biden campaign will respond to this he
gets pilloried by people is forced to
delete it and apologizes for daring to
link to the New York Post so there's
such a a guilt called happens yeah and
and and there's no backbone by a lot of
these journalists and if they get a
bunch of people yelling at them on
Twitter they're gonna just do what the
mob says and so so that's not changing
either that's only getting worse I think
in this new era yeah I think Republicans
are starting to wake up and just some
people have talked to sort of behind the
scenes there's this realization that
yeah we got we have to do more than
we've done in the past to win elections
we got to do the ballot harvesting but
in general we we have to sort of build
out just a bigger ground game because
Democrats have a billion dollar machine
that's been in place for decades
Republicans don't have that Republicans
have a system where the donor class sort
of gives money to the RNC who does it
out how they see fit where on the
Democrat side they have all these
organizations that have been built out
at the Grassroots level these
billionaire donors give to those
organizations and you know the party is
a little bit further down the list so
there's a whole machine apparatus that
that needs to be built on the right but
it seems like people are more inclined
to actually do the work right now and
want to build those things out Scott
Pressler is a guy who's running across
the country right now trying to register
voters trying to uh spread the word
about ballot harvesting and do what he
can to build those systems out and I
think it as far as what I'm seeing even
just this week Charlie Kirk posted about
this there's more of a focus now on
doing the work that's needed to build
out those systems to try to give Trump
the best chance or whoever is the
nominee most likely Trump but whatever
Republican candidate is the best chance
to uh to win the election next year but
here's the plan we need to use their
platform against them that the
strategies they have they've used
against us work needs against them so
when they say vote blue no matter who
here's the pitch Donald Trump runs as a
Democrat we all then vote for him in the
primary and now they have to vote for
they have literally have no choice
Checkmate Democrats it's beautiful
that's right it's going to be like I'm
sorry vote blue no matter who and
they're like put Donald Trump those are
your rules and then they're gonna have
to press the button for Trump oh and
that's how he wins but it is funny that
they say vote blue no matter who because
it clearly shows that you could put
literally anything in the office they
don't care as long as they're hurting
you that's crazy when was the last time
fetterman was seen recently
I mean it was kind of sad yeah I mean
really really sad I tried to read a
statement legitimately yeah he's talking
really weird he's struggling to form
words he can't he can he he clearly
can't understand the responses he's
getting and then he just ignores them
right he'll like ask a question he'll be
like can you
explain
to me why and if Biden is President and
then they say something and he goes
now have you seen and it's like well did
you are you gonna answer the first thing
they said like he just Boop just didn't
happen I guess yeah and that's with
someone literally running around next to
him with a screen in front of him that
has the words you know the closed
captioning happening and still is not
really comprehending no but that I'll
take whatever they can get as long as
not a republican yeah well that I mean
you got Biden now too right running
again and it's like really are we doing
this I mean it's hilarious
something I don't think Biden can win I
don't know I I I I will I will be
laughing come 2024 when I find out I'm
wrong or whatever but Biden had the
covid lockdown Advantage he didn't do
anything or go anywhere now they're
saying there's going to be no debates if
you guys heard this yeah no debates at
all none on either side on either side
it's none
I just this is crazy but whatever I
guess Trump's gonna try to get out of
him but I mean there's got to be RNC
debates you know he he obviously is a
former president but he's not the
incumbent so they've got to do RNC
debates and whether he's there or not
DNC I could if you really are have a
feel that's Joe Biden Robert F Kennedy
Jr and Marion Williamson I could see
them really just saying yeah you know
you're on your own you know it's going
to be used to be Biden here although
again I I don't know how you Galvanize
behind a person that you I got it yeah
here's what we'll do we will host the
Democratic debates
here Tim guest IRL right here but what
likely will happen is Biden won't come
but guess what I am willing to bet uh uh
RFK Jr will yeah and uh so would Miriam
Williamson for sure yeah and and if if
we're like look we'll do a legit we'll
get a forum we'll get a we'll rent a
building we'll get a you know an actual
theater we'll have anyone who wants to
run and the interesting thing is these
are prominent figures RFK Junior and
Marion Williamson but I wonder if any
other establishment Democrat who wants
to run would actually come yeah right is
it isn't uh who else is running what's
his what's his face
I don't know if there's anyone else
um have you interviewed RFK yeah uh uh
yes here we go uh hey uh Hutchinson on
the he's a GOP GPU oh it's GOP Acer oh
whoops I'm an idiot no he's I mean he's
okay he's right he's establishment
enough that he's right I know I was just
like he's he's one of those guys isn't
he yeah he's a pretty never Trump so uh
you know you see how I got confused yes
if you're spend all your days in like
cable news green rooms then you're
basically a Democrat at this point right
which is what he said so is it just RFK
Junior then Megan Williams I think so
far oh that's fantastic yeah we uh we
I'm pretty sure we've reached out to RFK
Juniors team and he'd be a great I mean
he's a fascinating guy super smart
um you know we've at the Megyn Kelly
show we've interviewed him a couple
times
um and you know how to had to keep an
eye out to make sure we could keep it
all on live on YouTube and all platforms
we will we will do the Democratic
debates live on Rumble with Marion
Williamson and RFK Jr and if Joe Joe
Biden will be invited right we'll say
hey man you just let her know let us
know what you need you're invited
absolutely well anything you anything
you need to make this debate happen and
then when he says no he just won't be at
the debates right so there you go to him
just like any other uh I think that'd be
and and I think Marion Williamson and
RFK Jr would have like a legitimate
debate when they had her on uh like
there there was so much screwing around
you know was it like Andrew Yang's Mike
got cut off yeah do you remember that
yeah and he's just going like mouthing
and like nothing's happening I explained
that if it was Donald Trump and they cut
his mic he would lean over and grab the
other person excuse me excuse me my
microphone is off I
that's Trump that's why Trump wins
because Trump would not let them silence
him and there's nothing they can do if
he if he's like Steps out of line and
says no I'm talking well that's the
thing he's polite to people or he's not
polite to people who aren't being polite
to him and so often that's what the
establishment depends upon they crap all
over everyone who's an outsider and
tries to stand up to them and then they
go oh sorry yes I'm sorry okay I'll go
along with it we saw this with
Republicans time and time again you're
racist you're a sexist home of your
homophobic you're terrible or they would
just ask them questions where that was
the subtext and they'd go I just want to
be very sensitive to your concern and I
want you to know I really do care about
you and your values in trouble like
you're an idiot shut up it's like great
that's they that's kind of what they
deserve well I Trump's not mean to
people who aren't mean to him no that's
what I'm saying in fact no no the when
it came to the bump stock ban when they
go to Trump and they say let's work
together he goes okay and then he agrees
with them if the Democrats went to Trump
and they said you're so smart your
policies are amazing we think you're
going to be the best here's what you
need to do he'll go absolutely I agree
and he would sign it in fact he actually
said in an interview with Tucker
recently he was talking about how Gavin
Newsom was so nice to him and the real
story is there Gavin Newsom understood
how to play Trump yeah you you be nice
to him you ask for things and he'll give
it to you and he didn't he got he here's
what I need for California okay sure you
know you flatter him I mean that you
know you play the game a little bit but
honestly like I I was just going back
and watching some of those private
primary debates with Trump in 2015 2016.
I mean it was so great television and
also honestly gets the point of why the
media became what they became because
they were all in on it they I mean CNN
and MSNBC they would put him on all the
time he was on Morning Joe and calling
in from the bathroom he was on you know
Don Lemon all the time he was talking
everybody and they did it because they
would love to have him be the nominee
and then they knew he would lose to
Hillary and so they're like all right
great let's ride this it's great ratings
and then they get that shock on November
8th and and they don't know how to how
to deal with it but in that moment they
were they were all good for the for the
TV yeah oh yeah I guess Zucker felt
personally responsible at CNN yeah so he
was offended because like or ashamed
because there are people being like they
would come to him and say why did you
give him all this air time and he was
like we were making money and so then he
made it his mission to just destroy
Trump in the Press right yeah and it's
hilarious because all they did was
expose themselves as biased destroyed
whatever remaining credibility they had
and made people who already like Trump
like him a whole lot more now what I
find so hilarious about the entire
situation is that you're correct that
people who flatter Trump seem to get
ahead in some sense and the left could
have very easily played him in that way
but because their TDS was so strong it
was like this perfect storm where this
weakness of his couldn't really be
exploited by them because they were too
deranged they were too histrionic over
and there was freaking out and screaming
it's Donald Trump it's like if you if
you were just as dishonest as you always
are and tried to flatter him you might
have been able to get some of the things
done that you wanted to get done but
you're not capable oh and I think one
other thing by Jeff Zucker because
that's that's what makes it so unique
about Donald Trump I mean Jeff Zucker
and Donald Trump go way back you know
Donald Trump made Jeff Zucker at NBC
because of The Apprentice it was a huge
hit Jeff Zucker had no hits before that
when he ran NBC he was Jeff Zucker was
one of the many media members who were
at Donald Trump's wedding to Melania in
2005. Katie Couric was there Matt Lauer
Barbara Walters you go right on Down the
Line Elton John performed I mean he was
part of that world for so long I mean he
was hosting Saturday Night Live in 2015.
he was he was in that world he was
hosting the Celebrity Apprentice in 2015
and he left and gave Arnold
Schwarzenegger a chance to do it right
before he announced for running for
president and then to become the
turncoat you know these people thought
they knew him they thought he was he was
their friend he was he was part of that
world and then he turned on him and that
that I think it became so personal for
so many of those people thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time